il faut donc que je commence par me
définir la meilleure façon de me décrire
et de dire que je suis très concerné par
la fraternité qui en fait est le
problème de tous les hommes
et je dois dire que j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir deux dont le premier celui
d'avoir la possibilité de chanter ce
dont je suis très contente
le second est celui d'éprouver un
sentiment de solidarité envers mes
frères mes soeurs vous aujourd'hui dans
le siècle du vivant les choses sont
extrêmement triste et il y a un grand
besoin d'essayer de créer par la
fraternité une société où nous cesserons
de tuer de torturer
c'est mon travail
je n'avais jamais entendu chanter devant
6000 personnes comme on chante devant un
feu de bois pour quatre ou cinq amis ça
c'est extraordinaire je n'avais jamais
entendu et ni vu quelqu'un chanter sans
avoir l'air de chanter c'est à dire
donner l'impression de n'avoir même pas
conscience de chanter il est très
possible en fait de chanter devant 6000
personnes comme si on chantait devant un
groupe d'amis à condition bien sûr que
la réaction du public soit chaleureuse
et simple comme elle l'était awk en
série je viens de soirée en italie
devant un public assez mystérieux j'ai
été attaqué le casino louis c'était pas
des fascistes
ici en france le concert a été comme une
bouffée d'air pur j'aime comme à paris
en pleine lumière
j'aime voir le visage des gens ça brise
les barrières
la situation d'aujourd'hui est
absolument sans espoir pourtant le
potentiel d'espoir est dans le regard
des jours je travaille aux états unis où
se trouve le potentiel le plus grand de
terreur et de violence car c'est le pays
le plus puissant je suis citoyenne de
ces dépressions voilà pourquoi si nous
disons aujourd'hui des choses agréables
ces belles ça me gêne c'est comme si
nous collaborions moeurs qui secoue la
wii en réalité j'allais dire que les
choses agréables belle je voulais dit
presque comme si elle ne vous était pas
destinée c'est à dire comme si elles
étaient destinées au delà de vous a tout
de même quelque chose qui est
l'espérance en ce sens que je n'aime pas
par exemple les chanteurs dit engagé qui
se met devant une table avec un papier
un crayon et qui disent je vais faire
une chanson engagée pour moi le
véritable engagement c'est celui-là
c'est à dire celui qui consiste à avoir
beaucoup de talent et a développé un don
de sympathie tels que l'on fait passer
une espèce de message pourrait pas dire
un message de paix parce que c'est
encore trop serré les choses mais
disons un message de douceur et un
message d'espérance yasmeen droit
voilà c'est là que commence par jobs
rappelait aux gens qu'il existe un
espoir bien sûr si on calcule les
chances de l'espérance est décourageant
cecon calmer une montagne en plein
avalanche
les hommes ont toujours refusé d'assumer
le refus de tuer il ya des guerres parce
qu'on croit qu'il faut tuer pour régler
les conflits
il existe pourtant un autre moyen et
nous devons y travailler
si nous voulons faire à ce maître se
respecte et éliminer la violence de nos
programmes très peu l'ont essayé il ya
eu bien sûr et gandhi martin luther king
danino dolce nous devons comme le
combattre souffrir mais refusé d'apposer
la souffrance aux autres sinon il y aura
très peu d'espoir de survie pouet les
gens souvent sont furieux lorsqu'on
parle de supprimer la violence graves
violences il l'appelle en fait auto
défense pourtant la question est ce un
vrai mais au cours des siècles est ce qu
on a seulement appris comment se
défendre autrement que par la violence
on défend un pays on n'apprend pas
défendre la vie humaine est la protéger
c'est pour que cela que je brille si on
pose le problème des méthodes de la non
violence
on trouvera des indications qui nous
permettent d'agir dans le sens de la
non-violence gandhi savait qu'il n'y a
pas de moyens le gard entre elles
il n'y a pas moyen de savoir quand on va
mourir comment sauf si on se suicide
bien sûr mais ce qu'il faut savoir c'est
comment il va mieux maintenant à demeure
si je vous ai demandé à la suite de tout
ce que vous avez dit si je vous ai
demandé de chanter c'est que je pense
qu'il n'y a pas de mauvais moyen pour
parler de la vie humaine de la tendresse
de l'amour de la non-violence et je
crois qu'il n'y a pas de séduction
interdite
et comme la vôtre et peut-être dans
votre sourire mais beaucoup aussi dans
votre voix c'était dans le sens où vous
parliez que j'allais en vous demandant
de chanter ça n'était pas du tout pour
vous demander de faire spécialement du
spectacle mais c'est qu' il n'y a pas de
mauvaises séduction toutes les
séductions sont bonnes quand il s'agit
de parler d'un
au sens large du mot aussi un extrait de
la chanson qui m'a donné le plus grand
courage
hanoi sous les bombes pourtant je ne
pouvais contrôler mes genoux qui
tremblaient tout mon corps trembler le
seul moyen de dominer ma peur c'était de
chanter en dépit des dons parvenait même
à les oublier ces bombes qui tombent et
très peu dingue et qu'il sait tout
tremblé
[Musique]
qui pour new york et qui portent talkie
walkie got to free
[Musique]
m
à propos d'autres opprimés pas beaucoup
de mots non plus mais il faut bien
employer les mots qui passe j'aimerais
bien que vous me chantier les conscrits
toulouse et chantait l'autre jour
j'étais swing low swing chez votre
manière swing souidi ville chérie
un communiqué
mais
[Musique]
sweet cherrie
un communiqué
et mai
avant
what you get
le communiqué
mais
[Musique]
la marine à me calmer
au touquet
you know
le dr ian e
le voile est là
camille
il y avait
[Musique]
mais promis il voit ta came
au touquet
[Musique]
et mes enfants
oui moi
ou celui dit chéri comme il déclaré
[Musique]
swing low sweet chariot
ah oui
camille au touquet
mais à
[Musique]
en
moi
c'est beau et c'est très beau et dans la
mesure où vous vous adressez à beaucoup
de jeunes gens et si vous voulez si on
peut aller un petit peu dans le sillage
de de l'espérance de la joie de vivre
quand même j'aimerais bien que vous me
donniez une petit exemple de ses
chansons que vous avez chanté en numéro
2 je crois vous avez annoncé tout
simplement que c'était une chanson
complètement idiote
j'aimerais bien à l'époque j'avais 14
ans j'ai chanté devant 800 personnes à
l'école mais je tremble exactement comme
si j'étais un homme sous les bombes et
j'ai santé cette chanson you lie
[Musique]
p
madame
[Musique]
ap